[Music]
maggie is with us in washington d.c hi
maggie how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
we deserve what's up
um so i just um my husband and i are
trying to figure out we're in baby step
two and we're trying to figure out if we
should
trade in two of our cars um for um
or used cars that would um be like you
know a lot more
cost effective so we could get rid of
our car payment it was hard to let that
come out of your mouth wasn't it
[Laughter]
i listen to you every single day and
it's surreal
[Laughter]
so uh all right tell us about tell us
about the cars car number one what do
you owe on it what is it worth
okay so it's a volkswagen atlas 2018 um
we owe about 11 000 on it it's worth um
we went to a dealership yesterday we got
them up to 19
on that wow and that one was still paint
yeah
and that one we're still paying and then
the other one is a 2009 jeep liberty
and that one is paid off
at first they came to us at 2700 i got
them up to five
what is your household income
it's about 145. how much data have you
got
um we have 81
982 left
i would not sell these cars unless you
don't like them
okay
yeah um
yeah
yes
i mean the idea was really exciting
because it would expedite the process um
and i'd like to um just knock this out
as soon as i can it's just hanging over
my head every day this debt
um
if you told me 81 000 and you had a 30
000 car debt
yeah yeah but 11 000 of 81 is not your
problem is it
i know yeah
well you're still gonna need something
to drive and that's not i mean you'd
only have about what eight thousand you
just get rid of the eleven thousand
dollars in debt and buy a car right
right
yeah exactly exactly um we have three
kids so we're not trying to get like the
oldest
car on the block with when we're driving
on the highway and stuff so um we do
like the car the atlas but the payment
it just i feel like it's just
taking a while to get rid of it what's
the rest of the debt
uh student loans
um
student loans really yeah
how long you've been working on all this
the ramsey way
so um we started in 2020
um and we were making some headway and
then um last year so at the end of 2020
we had our third child
and
long story short um it just ended up
being like a very difficult year um i
was in like survival mode
he had a lot of health issues it just
fell off the wagon
and just didn't do anything
he's a lot better he's still um
crazy but much better health-wise so um
he's just our wild one and we're
definitely done now
but
so we've decided to get back on track
and we paid off about um
about 7 000 so far and at the end of
this year we're supposed to have this
card paid off at the end of this year
here's here's what i heard
and you can tell me if i'd if i heard it
wrong uh
we've just been through hell
and i'm tired
and i'm desperately looking for a
quicker easier way to do this
and i was hoping this was it
yeah
yeah no that's
that's great
and and uh so
the the good news is you get to keep the
car the bad news is because it's not the
problem uh the bad news is now it is
game on girl yeah now you just the rest
of that garbage is in the rearview
mirror most of it anyway thank goodness
sorry you've been through all that it's
hard i mean it's been a hard year hard
couple years for a lot of us
and emotionally and stress and
everything else and just the whole the
the climate in the culture right now is
just bizarre so it's just affecting
everything but the uh uh
but yeah i i'm sorry you've been through
that here's the trick though
mathematically and actually
90 percent of you getting out of debt is
you guys getting
gazelle intense
on a budget
working the plan
no eating out no vacations no freaking
life and we're gonna clean this mess up
you make a hundred and forty five
thousand dollars you should be debt free
in 18 months
that was i was thinking 15 bucks okay
i'll go with 50. i'll go with 15.
and for that you don't sell the car the
car the car accelerates that by one and
a half to two months
right point being it does not solve the
problem
right if you cut the time in half from
18 months to nine months your car sold
girl i'd be throwing it out right now
for you for you right
yeah you guys have a really good shovel
i mean it'd be a bit more concerning if
you didn't have such a high income but
you do have a good shovel to work with
and like dave said you could knock this
out
easily in under two years you could
still live on six figures and knock this
out in two years so it's like if you
guys get gazelle intense you can do that
even faster so um yeah you playing did
you do you playing sports when you're a
kid
uh i no i did cross country okay cross
country that's a sport
and so uh you're running what three what
is that three mile run usually in high
school
yeah usually yeah so the first
mile and a half of your three mile run
you fell twice and skinned your knees
oh and your hands while you're at it
okay now you got the rest of the run
left you're not going to fall in this
part of the run
but
those falls
are are causing you to have to suck it
up and get with it
and and it's hard it's hard to overcome
the pain
of the first half of the race you had a
painful first start on this
and uh
you know i think it's just smart to say
it out loud uh you know those are
legitimate reasons that you you didn't
fall off the wagon girl you got knocked
off the wagon
and it's legitimate pain you felt it
it's real your knees are skinned your
hands are skinned you fell yeah and it's
uh it's okay to say that but what that
means is once you say it out loud you go
and
game on
second half
we got the crap beat out of us in the
first half we're going back in the
second half and take them back i'm gonna
take this game back yep i ran cross
country in high school and that speaks
to my heart i mean i just remember the
middle of the race especially if you had
a bad first half feels so disheartening
you're just like oh i don't know if i
can go on but man when you round that
corner and you start getting closer to
the finish line you're gonna feel
your spirit lift again you just have to
get through this really hard middle it's
lifting the chin up and looking at that
finish line and reaching for that
instead of gazing in the rearview mirror
and uh it's hard it's emotional
but i'm just saying i'm agreeing with
you it's been difficult
but that's all you're just gonna use
that as motivation for the second half
game on
15 months girl i want to hear from you
i'll hear your debt-free scream yeah
come see us we're proud of you we love
you get after it